9 7 4
m
et voici la couleur au jour fixé et à
l'heure dite madame mademoiselle
monsieur vous qui maintenant nous voyez
tels que nous sommes vous cesserez très
vite je ne sais bien d'être sensible à
la magie de la chose et vous trouverez
bientôt tout à fait naturel de voir la
vie avec ses couleurs envahir vos écrans
je voudrais tout de même vous demander
au moins en ce premier jour de
considérer qu'il s'agit là d'un tour de
force technique et d'une petite
révolution
je voudrais donc d'abord remercier ceux
qui ont rendu possible cette mutation
décisive dans l'histoire de notre
télévision d'abord l'inventeur monsieur
henri de france inventeur du procédé
français c'est calme
puis tous eu un gène year techniciens
ouvriers qui ont contribué à la mise au
point technique et industriel de cette
invention
puis les industriels français qui ont
réussi à mettre sur le marché à la date
convenue leurs premiers récepteurs et
cela n'a pas été facile je ne sais et
enfin bien entendu lors ftf représenter
autour de moi qui depuis des années
préparer ce rendez vous ce rendez vous
il a fallu pour le tenir beaucoup
d'efforts à tous et encore une fois je
les en remercie
je sais bien que pour l'instant nos
images en couleurs ne sont accessibles
qu'à quelques privilégiés et qu'elles
ont un certain caractère confidentiel
encore mais je veux espérer
que l'engouement du public la qualité
des programmes de la rtf vous proposera
est aussi le désir qu'a le gouvernement
le faire en sorte que la télévision en
couleur soit un phénomène populaire
modifieront profondément les conditions
du marché et rendre accessible la
télévision en couleur au plus grand
nombre des français avant de passer la
parole à monsieur jacques bernard dupont
directeur général de l'oha rtf
je voudrais tout de même présenté deux
brèves remarques
la première c'est que la télévision en
couleurs c'est une révolution technique
mais aussi une révolution dans notre
manière de devoir c'est à dire de penser
et de sentir
c'est une révolution artistique
également car la couleur ce n'est pas le
noir et le blanc colorier c'est quelque
chose de nouveau et de différent et cela
va poser aux artistes aux réalisateurs
de lower tf aussi bien qu'aux
techniciens des problèmes nouveaux et
difficiles
encore une fois c'est une opération
difficile que nous entreprenons ici ma
deuxième remarque se doublera d'un voeu
il est bon de constater que l'image la
plus belle la plus chatoyantes l'image
en couleurs est en même temps la plus
vraie et la plus proche de la vie qui
est en couleur
c'est là un symbole assez encourageant
pour un ministre de l'information et
tour un gouvernement
je veux donc souhaité du fond du coeur
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs que
votre vie quotidienne soit de plus en
plus vrai de plus en plus belle est de
plus en plus coloré
mais pour le reste à vous de juger comme
le disait léonard de vinci l'oeil se
trompent peu moins que l'esprit nous
aurions souhaité bien sûr d'être jugé
aujourd'hui précisément par le plus
grand nombre
nous savons que pour des raisons
parfaitement compréhensible cela ne peut
pas être le cas mais nous avons fait un
gros effort pour que ce programme
inaugural puissent être suivis par le
plus de téléspectateurs possible ainsi
aujourd'hui à la maison de l'eau arte
est fait pour tous les jours qui vont
suivre des récepteurs dans couleurs sont
à votre disposition pour suivre les
programmes couleurs de l'office de même
aujourd'hui dans toutes les stations de
lower tf en province des démonstrations
sont organisées pour que vous puissiez
voir la qualité des programmes couleurs
qui vous sont proposés notre voeu reste
tout de même celui que vous puissiez
très vite recevoir chez vous ces
programmes les recevoir dans les
meilleures conditions et monsieur
mercier et directeur de l'équipement des
exploitations vous dira peut-être dans
les conditions dans lesquelles une telle
réception est possible bien sûr la
télévision en couleurs c'est
certainement beaucoup plus complexe que
la télévision en noir et blanc aussi
bien pour nous ce n'est pas nous
techniciens ont ce jour ou quittent le
secret du laboratoire désir pour
pénétrer chez l'usager
ce n'est pas un commencement c'est un
aboutissement l'aboutissement d'une très
longue période période de préparation
très minutieuse nous avons essayé
précisément de nous mettre dans les
conditions les meilleures pour que
précisément au moment où commence ce
service régulier nous puissions garantir
à l'usagé des signaux qui souhaitent
aussi correct que possible je passe sur
la mutation monsieur le ministre nous
avait parlé en ce qui concerne
l'équipement la transformation de nos
matériels mais ceci si vous voulez c'est
notre affaire
maintenant il s'agit que chaque jour
nous puissions livrer ses signaux comme
je le disais tout à l'heure dans leur
perfection et cela je pense que nous
sommes prêts
encore faut-il que ces signaux soit
traduit également dans de très bonnes
conditions chez le récepteur de l'usagé
est là aussi j'ai parfaite confiance
dans l'expérience que nous avons une et
soit monsieur dupont depuis quelques
mois de certains récepteurs qui nous ont
été mis à notre disposition on a pu se
rendre compte que les réglages étaient
parfaitement stable
encore faut-il que ces réglages soit
fait est que ces réglages tienne c'est à
dire que l'usager n'aura prendre
quelques précautions
il ne pourra pas modifier l'emplacement
du récepteur réglé disons à sa
convenance et sans prendre dix ans la
précaution de faire revoir le réglage de
ce récepteur il devra prendre quelques
précautions concernant l'éclairage
ambiant du tube par exemple mais avec
ses précautions
je pense que une main d'un bout à
l'autre de la chaîne depuis la caméra
jusque ses usagers nous sommes prêts
pour une exploitation quotidienne de la
couleur reste maintenant les programmes
sont désormais nos responsabilités les
milliers in iraq ternat télévision ce
rendez vous d'aujourd'hui est le
résultat d'un tour de force technique
des services de leur tf et il ne faut
jamais oublier de les remercier mais la
parole appartient désormais à ceux qui
sont chargés de donner à la télévision
tout son sens c'est à dire d'en faire le
véhicule des moyens d'information de
culture d'enrichissement sous toutes
leurs formes s'adressant au plus grand
nombre à ce travail la direction des
télévisions s'est préparée elle aussi
depuis longtemps et elle vous présente
ses premiers deux premiers fruits de ses
efforts aujourd'hui mais elle n'oublie
pas que ce programme en couleurs avec
tous l'enrichissement que la couleur lui
apporte ce programme n'est vu en
couleurs que par un petit nombre et
qu'il faudra un certain nombre
- sinon d'années pour que la couleur
devienne un phénomène véritablement
populaire implanté dans tout le pays
c'est pourquoi il convient de rassurer
dès aujourd'hui et téléspectateurs
ancien est habituel de l'eau erdf
il rompt ils recevront les mêmes
programmes et la qualité de ses
programmes ne sera pas pour eux atteinte
il faut comme je viens de le dire
monsieur denise l'information que la
couleur apporte au plus grand nombre de
français le maximum d'enrichissement et
la direction de la télévision
si on peut re ah